I mean just in Shelby Park in an Eagle
pass in specific I mean it is cleaned up
it is day and night difference I mean I
was down there I would say at the
beginning of January and I mean they
went I did a little tour with National
Guard they were nice enough to let me in
and actually go and see the razor wire
and you know they kind of gave me the
ends of how many Crossings had actually
been stopped on average they were
averaging anywhere when I was down there
it was six to four migrants a day
compared to you know I was there the
month prior no 6 to four that's it wa
wait with with National Guard in Shelby
Park in one of the regions in the Del
Rio sector that used to be one of the
most popular and I mean they were
shattering records every single month
per day yeah well in the month before
that if you guys saw the kind of makeup
apprehension site where you had
thousands I mean filling in every single
10 minutes as one line is cleared
another line fills that's how much of a
difference that it has made in that one
sector so now you're seeing rises in the
Arizona sectors and migrants are making
their way over there or 15 miles you
know Upland and now they're Crossing in
that area but it's still not nearly as
much